Love it or hate it, there's never been a film
quite like "Space Jam: A New Legacy."
Set in the Warner Bros. "ServerVerse," it's
packed with references that will go over the
heads of younger viewers.
These are the things only adults will notice
in "Space Jam: A New Legacy."
Sure, LeBron James has his name above the
"Space Jam" sequel's title, much like Michael
Jordan did in the original "Space Jam."
But, also like that 1996 film, the villain
team is composed of mutated versions of basketball
superstars.
This time around, rather than the Monstars,
we get the Goon Squad.
This team includes both NBA and WNBA star
players, but with some significant upgrades.
"Okay, let's analyze the competition!"
Klay Thompson becomes "Wet-Fire," a Goon who
has aquakinesis (the ability to control water)
and pyrokinesis (the ability to manipulate
fire).
The nature of the character is a reference
to the "Splash Brothers," a moniker given
to Thompson and Stephen Curry because of their
ability to "splash" the ball with three-point
shots, and a riff on the old "Bash Brothers"
nickname bestowed upon '80s baseball superstars
Jose Canseco and Mark McGwire.
Anthony Davis is the Brow, a winged creature
with a unibrow.
Also based on a real nickname, Davis has gained
notoriety not only for his skills on the court,
but for, well, his unibrow.
Diana Taurasi appears as White Mamba, a snake-like
being.
The character name is a reference to one the
late Kobe Bryant bestowed upon her years ago,
praising her skills on the court by riffing
off his own "Black Mamba" moniker.
Damian Lillard becomes Chronos, perhaps the
most powerful of the Goon Squad.
He's basically an android who can speed up
and slow down time to his liking.
The character's inspiration comes from "Dame
Time," a phrase that has followed Lillard
since he was 13, referring to his ability
to stay calm under pressure and seemingly
control time as he casually blows past the
competition.
Finally, WNBA Sparks forward Nneka Ogwumike
is the scary Arachnneka, a spider-like Goon
with six arms.
There are a ton of jokes in "Legacy" about
LeBron's near-constant movement from one basketball
team to the next.
Since his 2003 debut, despite being a four-time
Most Valuable Player and 17-time all-star,
he has played for the Cleveland Cavaliers,
the Miami Heat, the Cleveland Cavaliers (again),
and now the Los Angeles Lakers — who, as
Don Cheadle's Al G. Rhythm jokes, better not
get too used to him.
Bugs' chosen nickname for King James is "Cleveland,"
not only a reference to his Ohio-upbringing
but also the city that has loved (and hated)
and loved (and hated) him as he has come and
gone over the years.
The funny thing is, at one time LeBron planned
to use a "Legacy" announcement to break Cleveland's
heart once again.
In 2018, as the world waited to see where
the free agent would land next, a teaser trailer
was prepared that reportedly had the Looney
Tunes characters stealing sports memorabilia,
with LeBron retrieving the memorabilia and
then appearing in full Lakers gear.
It would have served the dual purpose of teasing
the film and announcing James' new home — but
was ultimately scuttled at the last minute.
There's a good chance your child may have
seen the original "Space Jam," and if so there's
also a good chance they remember the name
Michael Jordan.
That would help with the funniest scene of
"A New Legacy," when Sylvester the cat announces
at halftime that the lopsided score is okay,
because he just found another basketball great
to join the team — none other than Michael
Jordan.
After watching the lower half of a mysterious
figure enter the room to great anticipation,
the reveal is that the toons have accidentally
recruited Michael B. Jordan — the actor
— to help out.
He looks confused, a lot of popcorn gets tossed
around, and then he heads back to his seat
to watch the conclusion of the game.
It's a funny joke, but you can already imagine
parents all over the world saying "You know,
from 'Black Panther!'
The 'Creed' movies?
Um, 'Fantastic Four?'"
Oh well, someday they'll grow up and find
it really funny.
Early in the film, we flashback to Ohio in
the '90s, when a young LeBron learns the value
of hard work on the court — and of not wasting
his time on video games.
It's a cruel lesson, but one with a basis
in reality.
In real life, the now primitive-looking but
beloved-at-the-time Game Boy was all the rage
from its introduction in 1989 until the late
'90s.
The game we see LeBron playing is 1990's "Bugs
Bunny Crazy Castle," which featured the titular
Looney Tune scampering up ladders and being
sucked through tunnels Mario-style while grabbing
carrots and avoiding baddies.
Decades later, perhaps basketball fans can
be thankful that LeBron put away his childish
things.
But still, tossing a Game Boy in the trash?
In the '90s, such behavior would've been viewed
by most kids as nothing short of a criminal
act.
If you see "Legacy" with a child, don't be
surprised if they have lots of questions about
all the characters in the background.
As Al G. Rhythm explains, the crowd for the
big basketball game is made up of half "everyday
people" sucked into the ServerVerse by LeBron
James' social media, and half "iconic Warner
Bros. characters" who make up their own WB
universe.
The result is one of the coolest things about
the movie — if admittedly, done before in
movies and TV shows like "Ready Player One"
and South Park's "Imaginationland" trilogy.
"Count Chocula, Cinderella, Snarf from 'Thundercats.'"
The background of the final act is populated
by characters from "The Wizard of Oz," "Game
of Thrones," and even the violent Droogs from
"A Clockwork Orange."
If your kid catches the reference to the nun
from Ken Russell's 1971 trippy 17th-century
nightmare flick "The Devils," well, consider
us impressed.
There are also lots of WB cartoon characters
in the background of those basketball game
scenes — so kids should have no problem
identifying them, right?
Think again.
It seems highly unlikely that a kid in the
year 2021 is going to geek out over the Herculoids
— but protoplasmic creatures Gloop and Gleep
from the 1967 series are right there, cheering
on the Tune Squad in multiple scenes.
Peter Potamus can be seen floating above the
court in his magic flying balloon, flanked
by the likes of Space Ghost, Jabberjaw, the
Great Gazoo, Magilla Gorilla, Captain Caveman,
and others that kids most likely won't recognize
unless they're allowed to watch Adult Swim.
If they're hip, they might recognize "Rick
and Morty"; if they watched the 2020 Animaniacs
reboot on Hulu, they might be delighted to
spot Yakko, Wakko, and Dot hanging around.
But if they don't recognize the Scooby-Doo
gang and their Mystery Machine, well, it sounds
like your family has some cartoons to watch.
One fun element of "Legacy" is that Bugs and
LeBron must put together their team by roaming
the ServerVerse, finding Looney Tunes characters
who reside on planets themed around classic
WB movies.
To an adult, it's a fun detour — to a kid,
some explanation may be required.
The duo visit a DC-themed planet, where Superman
and other Justice League heroes are glimpsed
as Daffy Duck and Porky Pig are recruited
— most kids, one would think, would understand
those references.
After that, however, they enter the 2015 blockbuster
"Mad Max: Fury Road," which earned a hard
"R" rating and most likely isn't in the Saturday
morning rotation for kids.
The recruitment team also travels to a black-and-white
"Casablanca" world, where "Play it again,
Sam" takes on a whole new meaning.
Although a cartoon Humphrey Bogart appeared
alongside Bugs in "8 Ball Bunny," the legendary
actor doesn't appear in this version.
While seeing such prominent recognition of
the 1942 movie is wonderful, the scene might
soar over the heads of kids like LeBron going
for a dunk.
Perhaps most enjoyable is a visit to a "Matrix"
planet, where Granny and Tweety have become
a couple of bullet-dodging badasses.
Then there's the Austin Powers planet, where
Elmer Fudd has become a Mini-Me of Dr. Evil
and poor Sylvester has been shaven to become
the villain's new hairless pet cat.
As an adult, you might be jazzed to spot Wood
Harris, aka Avon Barksdale from "The Wire,"
playing LeBron's no-nonsense childhood coach.
But chances are, the children in your life
will be much more preoccupied looking for
Taz.
Other adult-friendly cameos in "Legacy" include
Sarah Silverman, stifling her famously foul
mouth temporarily to portray a duplicitous
WB executive.
Alongside Silverman is recent Oscar nominee
Steven Yeun as another eager exec.
LeBron's wife is played by "Star Trek" and
"Walking Dead" series vet Sonequa Martin-Green.
Then there are the basketball game announcers,
sucked in via their phones and told that unless
the Tune Squad wins, they'll become stuck
in the ServerVerse forever.
The guy in the bowtie is smooth-voiced sportscaster
Ernie Johnson, and to his left is Lil Rel
Howery, a funny supporting actor perhaps best
known for "Get Out."
Also worth mentioning is Zendaya as the new
voice of Lola Bunny, and funnyman Gabriel
Iglesias vocalizing Speedy Gonzales.
Adult and child fans of the classic Looney
Tunes cartoons alike will be rewarded for
their hours spent before the boob tube, as
certain moments in "Legacy" recall classic
shorts.
When LeBron first encounters Bugs Bunny, the
wascally wabbit shoves a hunter's cap and
a shotgun onto the basketball star, insisting
that he act out a scene.
LeBron goes through a few physical transformations
as he becomes a cartoon, one resembling the
"early version" of Elmer Fudd seen in cartoons
like 1942's "The Wacky Wabbit."
Bugs and LeBron also keep tearing "Rabbit
Season" and "Duck Season" signs off the tree,
re-creating one of the most iconic cartoon
sequences ever committed to film: the Bugs
and Daffy square-off in 1951's "Rabbit Fire."
While LeBron attempts to explain his dilemma
to Bugs — his son Dom has been kidnapped
by Al G. Rhythm and he needs to recruit a
basketball team to get him back — Bugs puts
the basketball star through a series of torturous
cartoon moments.
Perhaps the most recognizable is the barbershop
sequence from 1950's "The Rabbit of Seville",
with Bugs shaving and spinning his unwitting
victim in a barber chair.
Lots of other classic Looney Tunes bits are
littered throughout the film, from Marvin
the Martian's "You have made me very angry!"
to Wile E. Coyote's backfiring Acme products.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
summer blockbusters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.